[Applause]
so at this time there's no official
release date for the next tekken game
confirmed by bandai but with all this
talk about tekken 8 we gathered some
ideas from players on their expectations
and what they want to see in the next
tekken game
[Music]
cross platform
cross play gives a meaningful impact on
matchmaking and better quality for
online
now if this feature is added on tekken 8
it can help the game to be more
consistent due to increased player pull
seven hours later
it'll minimize the waiting time in
searching for opponents and will give
you a wide variety of players to
encounter new challenger thus makes
online play more enjoyable
[Music]
[Music]
it was
it was all just a dream
legacy characters return
so there's still a lot of questions if
some of the old characters will return
in tekken 7 not to mention if there will
still be a new season after season four
now we don't want to get our hopes up
too high for this but maybe they can
consider bringing them back in tekken 8.
[Music]
removing 2d characters
so the arrival of akuma and geese in
tekken 7 gave the fans a lot of hype
though there were some mixed opinions in
the tekken community especially the
professional scene bring it
some say we need them removed in the
next game and then some say i wish they
could stay
if by chance bamco decided to stick with
the 2d characters in the next one
maybe improvement in terms of balancing
would be the best choice
oh my god
not only to 2d characters but to other
op characters as well
[Music]
character stories
some characters in tekken outside the
mishima bloodline have really
interesting stories
maybe they can provide a conclusion or
continuation in tekken 8.
[Music]
don't lie to me i killed him with my own
hands
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
take
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you agree with this list
be sure to join our discord and share
your ideas the link is going to be below
the description
once again this is drew and thank you so
much for watching ochodo tv be sure to
subscribe for more sweet tips awesome
dad
let me try
[Music]
[Music]
you